the salah is said only to live near the
border between vietnam and laos it's a
species of long horned bovid more than 2
million years old
but first discovered in 1992 biologists
like Andrew tinker are trying to track
it down I dreamed of seeing a salawah
and even if I got a glimpse a two-second
glimpse it would make all of this all
the years of hard work it would make it
worthwhile he's only seen so Lola in
photos like this one at the far right
till Kerr is an American who's been in
Vietnam for three years working for the
World Wildlife Fund and working with
leeches Sola have been sighted in the
wild just five times it's hoped that
leeches will help find them the leeches
are feeding on these animals in the
jungle so we can collect the leeches and
analyze the DNA in the leech to see what
they fit upon
so if a soul Allah have been fed on it
would be visible in the leeches blood
20,000 samples have already been
analyzed but there's been no trace of a
soul Allah is that too much to spend on
a single species oh no oh no I don't
think so some people do but to me
thus Allah is is priceless and you can't
put a price tag on it
what's urgently needed is to win over
the population by teaching them to
recognize Sola and on no account to hunt
them simple games are being used to do
this like avoiding traps while
blindfolded there have been so Lola in
captivity but none have survived after
till Kerr says it's completely unknown
how many remain
could be up to a hundred it could be
that we can count the number of cell on
one hand so it's really searching for a
needle in a haystack
a search for one of the world's rarest
animals
you